um
elmswell
has a certain
literary ring about it if you think
perhaps
[Music]
mandalay with a an overlay of
of bleak house really
um
i've been there for 45 years so i'm
entitled to call it
elmsl
but um for the sake of clarity
uh i shall call it elm as well which
used to nestle rather cozily
on the old a45 god those were the days
midway between snow market and berry
we're now a bit less cozy
we're subject to forces
beyond our control
and we are classed rather soviet style
as an a14 coded a village
along with our much posher neighbors at
woolpit and thurston
this lack of control is known as nppf
insidious acronym
or ia
locally translated as
nice place to plonk
thousands of houses
all of them patent book
but we're assured by those purveyors of
snake oil the developers
that they are carefully designed
and cited to enhance our community
vitality
difficult not to spit at that point but
there we go
um
we're midway between felixstowe and
cambridge almost exactly so we're a
honeypot and subsequently
a 48
uplift in our houses over some eight
years ensures that we remain
the largest village in mid-suffolk
however our vitality remains it is
argued
despite this assault
rather than
of the benefit thereof
but towards a more general context we've
always been a working village for many
years we were synonymous with the elmsl
sorry elmswell bacon factory a victorian
farmer's co-op employing some 600 people
and ensuring that the meat raffle in the
pub was always worth entering
you could see the meat coming out of the
back door on the front never mind
our ambiance is
uh it's a french word they're the
ambiance the ambiance we have a very low
thatch quotient
we've never knowingly featured on a
chocolate box or a tin of christmas
biscuits
if ever we see a tourist
it's because they think they're in elm
set
we point them to colchester and they
hope the best
therefore
a typical resident's idea of considering
whether a building is worth listing
is if it's
listing listed slightly on the ho
not really switched on to that sort of
thing
the population thereof is 4 000 and
rising they never stand still so we
can't count them very well
our newsletter of which i've brought a
visual aid which i forgot
award-winning newsletter goes out every
month as it has done for 30 years but
now we're up to
2019 households a figure rising by the
month
this year's precept was
five hundred 163
fourteen pounds
uh the sixth highest in mid-suffolk so
we're not the real bad boys
so that's
what we are
our renewable energy saga began in 1998
in the days when as you'll recall
biodiversity was generally thought to be
a washing powder
and cop 26 was ian our local pcso based
at stone market police station
i made that bit up actually
it was then that we built and i now
press something and it says next
oh yes look at this
slide one
the first phase of a community facility
at blackburn to replace the 1950s
vintage memorial hall
you will see and i thought i could point
it out and perhaps i can
um
there's a sort of
gummy pink bit of the roof that was the
original hall that's what we built in 19
whenever it was
it involved two minor wars the building
of this facility
one with the developer who only finally
conceded as he
waded across a river of blood
the 11 acres of land which became
blackboard meadow so we're standing on
11 acres of land
and one
war with a vociferous cohort of
residents with connections to unvast
affection for the crumbling old edifice
significantly in our shiny new hall we
installed and here it says in my notes
pause for sharp intake of breath
muttered curses on the merest whiff of
brimstone
a gas boiler
hold that thought
in 2012 we expanded blackboard to
provide a community activity hall
which is
the the sticky up bit with the nicer
colored roof on it we've added other
bits as well but this was the main thing
that we added in 2012
by then we had our act together
with regard to sustainable heating and
decided to dig up the football pitch
there was some persuasion needed there
and to lay into a meter deep trench a
few thousand yards of horizontal plastic
tubing which continued indoors
there it is indoors
the theory was that the pipes would
collect the under soil heat
and convey it to the big
heat pump thingy in the plant room which
would boost it and send it to the
underfloor system
and it worked a treat
so our idea number one was successful
and if you decide to go that route
that's what it begins to look like it's
really very simple
i think it's quite special pipe but
i don't know
sure screwfix have got some
idea number two might be instructive we
had thought ahead
and we installed a bigger
heat pump thingy than was needed
and this we plugged into the radiator
system in the old hall
and that worked a tree
top tip
we kept the old gas boiler in situ just
in case
for a year or two absolutely pointless
it wasn't connected to anything but very
effective in suppressing the doubters
because we would tell them nobody if the
new system fails we'll turn the old
system on
it worked
so
and we did in fact if i go back
at some stage and i can't remember when
we threw in some solar panels for good
measure so those are they there
and so on
now we've contended all the way along
the pressure of development requires any
responsible community to address
the commensurate infrastructure
requirements within its remit and
control in other words if they're going
to dump it on you
there's no good arguing
deal with it
hence when the opportunity arose the
parish council purchased the redundant
methodist chapel in the village with a
community hall attached and looked at
the updating of another facility for the
village
and we should have
it there
so from an enormously long selfie stick
you can see
the original chapel which looks very
much like that today
here was the the old hall
and
[Music]
there it is
you'll recognize it possibly a structure
many might recognize a fine example of a
post-war village hall flat and brick
accidental attempts at sedum on the
corrugated roof here
which had to come off and critter
windows
the very last user of this hall was the
baby and toddler group
at the time we were monitoring
temperatures as part of the redesign
initiative
and the kiddies spent their very last
morning in the old hall
at four degrees c with their coats and
boots on
there are knowledge problems of old
victorian buildings in terms of thermal
efficiency
please see a taster here
so this is inside the chapel
stripped out
we were prompted by dry rot as well i
have to admit that but you can see i
mean what you've got is wall and then
the outside world and what you've got is
floor and then the underneath and what
you've got is ceiling and then the
outside world this is a problem
um you understand that
significantly we dug down the floor
lower than we needed to have because we
had this idea that once again we put
some of these pipe things in and have
another heat pump thingy
but this time
we didn't have enough room to lay them
flat
so we imported we got quite excited this
was the uh the big boys toys thing we
loved this we loved it so they brought
this drill thingy in and here it is
interesting to see how tightly it can
work so whatever your
however tight you are as long as it can
get in it can drill down
and it drilled five substantial holes
don't ask how deep they were in meters i
don't understand it
um around the very messy business
and the next bit is
quite easy much easier what you do is
you poke a pipe down
and then it feeds up again uh so you got
water going down and then coming back
and
the theory is that it comes back warmer
than it went in
i believe anything really um
[Music]
so
that goes indoors and this is the
indoors of the new build facility on
this second
uh exercise of ours so you'll see
exactly the same thing there's your
underfloor pipes
but in this case they've started to put
the screed on top
and the beauty of if you can do that if
you don't have to have a suspended floor
is that what you've got is an enormous
night storage heater it's brilliant
absolutely brilliant
sorry i'm preempting myself i'm supposed
to go through this and then say it works
so forget i said it was brilliant
um
if you have got a suspended floor
you don't want that this is in the wrong
order
no
no we've missed one
have we missed one somebody
somebody technical
yeah we've missed one no matter if you
have got a suspended floor i have uh at
home
a picture of a suspended floor in this
sorry in this state so ready ready for
the pipes to go in
and the way you do it is you just put a
bit of a wooden plank across it and then
you put the pipes underneath etc
and you don't clearly get the efficiency
of the night storage heater
so
we put all of that into something which
looked we took the roof off just to do
this picture for you
this is the chapel with a suspended
floor in it and this is the new facility
with what we call the coffee shop and a
meeting room and this is a coffee shop
with one of those
um barista persons we have barista
persons who come and make all those
noises
it's really exciting stuff and lots of
lavatories you have to have lots of
lavatories so that's what we were
heating with underfloor heating fed from
holes in the ground
with its roof on
the chapel now looks like that
so underneath here is underfloor heating
fed from holes in the ground
we had to augment it with radiators we
didn't want radiators we wanted a
beautiful completely empty void
ready for people to have weddings and
exciting things
that's what the radiators in but uh
we're a bit disappointed with that but
it was the only way we could guarantee
because however you can as you're aware
i'm sure i'm telling you how to suck
eggs you can only insulate old walls to
a certain extent if you go too far they
start to sweat and do all sorts of
horrible things and distort everything
so the architect chap
who we paid god bless him
um the architect you have advised so
we've got the maximum
that we could get in terms of insulation
a brilliant system of secondary glazing
here which you can't see in detail over
the old victorian we couldn't secondary
glaze that
great pity but we just couldn't do it we
would have ruined it so those
inefficiency means we had to have the
radiators but in the
coffee shop bit and there it is being
used as a coffee shop these are people
using a coffee shop so underneath here
again
solid floor warmest toast i was in there
today 21 with a very cold snap not a
problem at all
so there you have
three examples we've got
a big space
with underfloor in concrete we've
retrofitted
an old hall without any extra insulation
but because we've got a big heat unit
there that is working and again i was in
there this morning and that was at 21
again and the pilates ladies agreed it
was
very nice
thank you
and we've also then got the mixture here
of suspended floor with the vertical
drilling which means that there's no
excuse we haven't got the land to do it
just dig down as long as you can get
that machine in you can have uh
your pipes
there's more i'm not sure what it is
so i think we're here today we're
invited today because we have gained
this practical experience at several
levels involving community involving
heat pumps in community settings
and the big things
the big ticket
experience is
the ease of management if you are
managing a village hall and i'm managing
both of these
it is brilliant not to have to go to bed
thinking did i turn the heating off
and wake up thinking did i turn the
heating on
and then waiting for the heating to pick
up so the pilates ladies can
well that hurts so the pilates ladies
can do that thing that hurts um you
don't have to think about that you've
got this what they call low grade which
i think does a disservice you've got
this low grade heat coming in all the
time so i walked in this morning at six
o'clock god help us and it was 21 no
problem at all despite the fact it's
been the cold snap
so that is a big plus an enormous plus
the minus is the practical minuses it's
very unresponsive
if all of a sudden we have a heat wave
you're too hot the most common fault
we've had is too hot we get over the
first one by having a dozen ordinary
plug-in three kilowatt heaters and over
the last six or seven years we have had
to use those because it was it was too
cold three times
that's all
and what we have is this technical
approach to too hot
where we open the windows and that seems
it seems to work a treat really it
didn't cost us a lot
um what i can't talk about is the cost
we were in the lucky position of hitting
renewable heat incentive when it was
still going and we we reap enormous
benefits from that
we
always run our facilities at a profit
we've we've got enormous advantages over
smaller villages we've got enormous
demand
and we are tight
we we will do anything for money and so
but part of that was rhi it does mean
that the village is getting this
glorious warm facility
uh
at no cost effectively at no cost on the
rates
so i can't talk about cost and i can't
talk about the technicalities there are
so many people who know exactly how deep
the holes are how many holes you will
need and all of that and by the time i
tell you what we've done it's way out of
date i'm sure it is
a lot of things when you get to a
certain age
are terribly out of date
you realize when you put your pajamas on
every night
so we are completely sold on this
technology to the extent that i have
another slide
dick sends out now you'll recognize this
stop me if you've heard this one um
this is the
uh somewhere
where is it yeah here's the chapel
is it yeah this is the chapel here
this is the new build this is the
carhawk
next door immediately contiguous don't
you just love that word
immediately contiguous next door green
king suddenly decided to flog their pub
grotty old pub but they had in the
garden planning permission for eight
more desirable houses just waiting to
add vitality
to our village
um so we bought it
we went to the public works loan board
and if you're going to learn anything
today
if in doubt go to the folks whatever
they do exactly what they're saying
that's in they're brilliant
just don't tell the charge players a
little um so we went to pwlv and we
bought this site and
[Music]
we now have a pub which we bought as
occurring concern and we're keeping it
going
but we're going to repeat the wesley
experience there with the added bonus of
instead of the eight desirable
residences here we're putting ten
affordables we formed a community land
trust
and those affordables will be part of
a community heating program shared with
the pub
now i say that with all the confidence
of somebody who doesn't know what the
earth he's talking about no idea i've
never done it but we'll do it
because it's there to be done and the
beauty of all of this technology
is it's growing faster than your ideas
so by the time you get to doing it it's
easier and cheaper so although you
haven't got rhi renewable heat incentive
it doesn't really matter because the
prices have come down solar panels being
being the classic
so
the community gained to us in buying
that and in sorting out is very clear
at the heart of our built village and
this is literally in the middle of the
built village
uh handily opposite the chippy which is
great we will own and control a
considerable holding of land with
enormous synergy between the two of them
so a wedding in here
can enjoy the catering from here eaten
in here
it's just enormous one can be parking
because when they need parking the pub's
empty when the pub needs parking the
hall's not as full as it might be
etcetera you know so we have done that
um
and our pub will look we think something
like
this again we've taken the lid off just
for you
i could shop for this so here again you
will see enormous floor area and all of
this
i imagine will be
a solid floor with underfloor heating
from a community heat pump thingy but
shared with
10 houses if this can be done i'm sure
it can
10 affordable homes on the same site
um
this is from our share perspectives
because of course we've got to get the
money to to build this but we're working
on that we're well in advance a
community pub
uh so the graphic this graphic was drawn
up by our architect who got us to um
to project design stage so we're there
and we've paid him off
and he said to us
at a fairly early stage with a sense of
resignation i suppose you want heat
pumps again
and it was a pointless question really
because it's clearly the way to go and i
would suggest
if it's at all appropriate to any of you
it is definitely the way to go
that's all i have to say
yep